hey everybody
and welcome to our by lita meetup
we're just about to get started um i
hope you can hear me
[Music]
and while we get sorted out
i would encourage you to have a look
around the
zoo menu if you haven't already
for the question and answers during the
talks and afterwards we'll use the
questions and answers box so if you have
a question
during or after the talk feel free to
post it
likewise there should be a chat window
somewhere that you can use to introduce
yourself
and leave a message to to reach out
so we have at least one person that can
hear me which is great
so that means we can get started
um so once again yeah welcome for uh to
our meetup
we have a couple of great talks for you
tonight sorry i'm
just dragging around to the zoom windows
on my screen
um we have two speakers today
ellie bauer from the university of east
anglia is going to talk to us
about using deep learning to count
albatrosses from space
and then we'll have a short session for
questions and answers
and then we'll have a talk by um liz
cavallo
who's going to talk to us about going
from jupiter notebooks to production
code
using kedro
before we dive into the the meat of the
evening
we have a couple of announcements that
we want to run by you
um so as you probably are aware
um we are the the cambridge chapter of
the the pi data groups
group of meetups we've been
going strong since november 2018
so we're almost due our second
anniversary
and we hold monthly meetups like the one
that you're attending now every last
wednesday of the month
we used to be at the raspberry pi
building near the cambridge railway
station
but of course now we are online
and apart from myself so i'm
yours apart from myself there are three
other volunteers that organize
the meetup there's federico leandro and
ola
ola is here with me and
in the meetup and he will help to
streamline the the question and answers
and
answer any questions you may have hello
everyone
hey ola um with that in mind
um a little bit about um our
main um parent organization num focus
so as i mentioned we're part of the pi
data group of meetups
by data sponsored by the non-focus
organization
that tries to promote open code um
to basically promote better science
and um num focus does a number of things
apart from the meetups and the
conferences that you might have attended
it also sponsors a lot of the open
source packages that you
use and know and love um
so if you agree with the mission of
never focus please consider
donating or at least keeping an eye out
for news from from them focus
we have a code of conduct that governs
our meet up both in person and and
online
um it is basically what you expect
be kind be professional don't insult or
put down
other people and behave as you would
like to be treated with
if if you feel that you have
an issue that falls under the code of
conduct that you want to discuss
you can reach out to us the organizers
of the meetup
or to leonie mooc whose email address is
given at the bottom of the page so
if there's something that you feel more
comfortable discussing with
someone who's not an organizer feel free
to
reach out to leone
and then before we dive in um a quick
shout out and a big thanks to our
sponsors
so we we currently have a number of
corporate sponsors i've already
mentioned
num focus we're also very grateful to
raspberry pi who used to host us
in the flesh when there was such a thing
and then we have arm as a corporate
sponsor and fetch.ai
arm has a couple of job postings that we
want to
run by you if you're interested in any
of
those you can visit the arm
corporate careers page or talk to
in this case via meetup to to federico
or leandro
and then a couple of announcements
for events that may keep you occupied
while you while away your your time
under lockdown
so there's the pi data global conference
that's taking place
the second week of november
the call for proposals for that
conference has closed but you can still
um purchase tickets and anybody who's
attended uh the pi data cambridge or
london conferences
in the past probably knows that they're
chock full of
interesting and novel stuff and the pi
data global conference
will be no exception i'm sure and it has
the
benefit of bringing together a lot of
people with the same goals as yourself
um in an online platform
and then we have two smaller events that
may be of interest to you so from
tomorrow on
um the hacktoberfest starts
so you can support open source by
creating a number of contributions
and if you're within the first 70 000
people to do so you'll get a
free t-shirt or the opportunity to plant
a tree courtesy of digitalocean
some of the open source packages in the
scientific python universe like psychic
image i think and and scipy
and pandas have sprints and tickets that
you can contribute to
so be sure to check that out
and then there's there was another um
online hackathon that caught our
attention
hack hate 2020
this one starts the 11th of october you
can find more information at the
link below but it's more of a
conventional hackathon in the sense that
you um assemble teams online to work on
a specific problem
then you code for a couple of weeks and
then there's a
final round where the your work gets
evaluated
so be sure to to check those out if
um they are of of interest
and last but not least we're always
looking for
more speakers and for uh
sponsors so you can reach out to us on
twitter at
pidatacambridge and via email
at spideygimbridge gmail.com
in particular if you have an idea for a
talk but you don't feel confident
um or you want to run it by us to see if
it's appropriate
to do not hesitate to contact us we're
happy to to talk
and we're happy to help you develop a
proposal into something that's
um that can be presented to the meetup
and with that i'm officially at the end
of my little chat
so i'll stop sharing my screen and
i'll turn the floor over to
the speakers so the first speaker
that we have tonight is
ellie bowler
so as i already mentioned ellie is a
phd student at the
university of east anglia and she's
going to talk to us about
um deep learning and um tracing
albatrosses
ellie i don't know if you can share your
screen
uh yeah can you hear me at the moment
yes i can hear you
yeah loud and clear
i think it's saying um host disabled
participant
screen sharing uh i will click around
and
could you try again i've
clicked on
yes is that working yes
great okay
um sorry i haven't actually presented on
zoom yet so
that's all right this is also my first
zoom meeting hosting
can you see the main screen or is it
still on
uh we can still see presenter modes
okay i would just do it like
i'm sorry no that didn't work again
okay is that working now
yes i'm sorry
um yeah thank you very much for inviting
me to
um speak today it's really nice to
to join the meet up um so
like uh we were saying my name is uh
ellie
i'm a phd student at the university of
east anglia
um and i was just gonna give a bit of an
overview of my project i've been working
on which is
an application of deep learning and
computer vision for ecological
monitoring
of albatrosses um so it's just going to
quickly introduce people that i'm
working with
at uea so my main supervisor is macau
mosquitovic he's
worked a lot in color science and he's
sort of branching into a lot of more
um ecological monitoring projects um as
well as jeff french who's our sort of
deep learning
uh go-to guy and then um
my project's co-supervised at the
british antarctic survey
over in um cambridge so my main
supervisor there is
peter fretwell who is
a bit of a kind of pioneer of this
counting wildlife from space uh sort of
loads of different animals um and he
runs a lot of different projects and
a couple of other students are um hannah
who's working on accounting medicine
space
and uh prem who's looking at seals um
but today i'm going to talk about
albatrosses
which are just you know infinitely
better um
so uh i thought just give a bit of
background about albatrosses to say why
we're interested in counting them
um so albatrosses are a really unique
and
uh very charismatic um species they've
got the largest wingspan of any
uh living bird which is up to um three
and a half meters
and they use these wings to sort of
glide around uh very strong
uh aerial currents around the southern
ocean so
they live almost entirely on the wing
and hardly ever come to land apart from
when they're
uh nesting which is every two years
um so they're really uh
incredible animals um but unfortunately
like a lot of wildlife they do face a
number of threats
and so this is a very depressing slide
but um
the outros is actually the most
threatened of any bird species um so a
lot of this is to do with
uh long line fishing activity so they
get drawn in by these traumas and
caught up in hooks when they're fishing
for tuna mostly
um and they're also under threat for any
sort of super-sized mice which are
predating on
the chicks particularly on goth island
um and in
blue planet two they had an example of
where the chicks also being fed
plastic which have been um washed up in
the ocean so
there's a lot of uh pressures on
albatrosses and this has led to a lot of
concern over their conservation
and enhanced uh sort of measures for
trying to monitor populations
and check up on their health and also
inform conservation action um
but one of the problems with monitoring
albatrosses is that they
nest in extreme and remote locations and
so this map shows the
main nesting sites of wandering
albatrosses which is uh the main
species that i'm looking at um so as you
can see they're sort of got a
second polar distribution they're really
very remote islands quite extreme
weather conditions
it can be very dangerous um expensive or
just
um very impractical to access the
islands to conduct
surveys on
and it's also very expensive so it means
that um a lot of locations
uh there's very little monitoring um and
so there's not a very good understanding
of
actually how many there are in different
locations which sort of limits our
ability to properly inform conservation
efforts
and so these challenges really led
people to ask
whether there was another way that we
could survey the albatrosses without
physically having to go to these remote
rocks in the southern ocean
and one of the potential solutions was
using very high resolution satellites
and so this is sort of the newest
generation of
satellite imaging which can
sample anything under 50
centimeters so um there's a lot of
benefits of using satellites and they're
obviously already really widely used for
monitoring all sorts of
sort of landscape scale processes um
they're really useful in that they offer
global coverage so we can
get images of these really remote
locations without having to go there
particularly for wildlife monitoring a
big benefit is they're obviously
non-invasive so you can
get an image and you're not disturbing
the wildlife or
um the environment that they live in and
you can also get these sort of
permanent visual records which are
really useful because you can
and sort of compare your results to
different people you have um something
sort of
you can look at different ways of
analyzing it later down the line
rather than perhaps in a traditional
survey where you make field notes but
it's
maybe not so comparable across different
um studies
and so the one the satellite that we're
particularly looking at
is the currently the highest
resolution commercially available
imagery which is from the worldview 3
so this is run by uh maxa which is a
digital globe
company um it was launched in 2014 and
it offers
uh imagery at a 30 centimeter resolution
ground sample distance so roughly each
pixel on the image represents
about the size of a sheet of paper so
it's obviously incredibly
uh detailed and um it's used a lot for
a lot of different applications but
obviously
the one that we were most interested in
is whether
we could see albatrosses uh in the
in the newly launched satellite and so
this
was a study that my supervisor
peter over at the antarctic survey
carried out in 2017
and he was looking to see whether it was
possible to
identify wandering and also northern
royal albatrosses in the world v3
imagery
um and the answer of could we see them
was uh yes
just about so um this is an image of
a wandering albatross taken from space
so
it's not maybe the most exciting looking
image
but in terms of doing surveys it was
quite exciting because
you can just about make them out as
these sort of four to five pixel
white dots against their green nesting
habitat
um so that was kind of a bit of a
background of
can we see them um the next question
though is
how do we count them and so currently
this is
mostly done manually and so you would
get your
very large satellite image uh and load
it into
use your program like arcmap um and come
up with a method for
dividing and tracking where you've gone
and then just click on
uh any white dot which you interpret to
be an albatross
and so there's obviously a lot of
limitations with these methods
um it's very time consuming uh i think
even if you really really like
albatrosses it does get a little bit
boring
um it's quite error-prone and
really importantly and something that
i'll come back to is that it's
highly subjective um because there's a
huge amount of uncertainty over
what you're looking at our choices look
a lot like rocks
at 30 centimeter resolution um and so
each different person tends to produce a
different set of labels
um so it's not very standardized with
method
um and it creates a kind of bottleneck
if you want to roll out these satellite
surveys over
larger areas or at more frequent
intervals which we'd ideally do
and so the aim of this project really is
to try and automate this
counting method and see if we can sort
of streamline the process a bit more
and so to do that we wanted to try and
see if we could use
the sort of latest deep learning
approaches um so i've done this
as
the three stages i went to i was quite
new to the
deep learning and uh machine learning in
general when i started the project so
um this is how i sort of break it down
in my mind so the first
step that we did was build a data set
and so
one of the challenges with this field is
it's very
emerging and quite quite new so there's
not extensive data sets surprisingly of
high resolution albatrosses so um we
built this one which
is four um separate colonies which are
dotted all over
the southern ocean and so the images
were collected at
different times of year um different
times of day so there's quite a lot of
variation in them and these were
manually analyzed um just the way i was
shown before by
an expert at the antarctic survey so the
same person annotated
all of these four images um and gave a
total a total count
and so i think all scale we've got about
2 000 examples
of albatrosses across the four images um
which is a fairly decent number of
examples to try
um trains and deep learning methods
and so once we built the data set um we
then
wanted to come up with and train a
network
so the architecture that we went for was
quite simple uh unit architecture
and a segmentation method um
this was had been successful with
uh someone else um jeff french in the
group who worked in a similar project
and so we thought we'd test it out on on
this data set and
we used transfer learning so we um used
some of the feature maps from a
vgg16 uh pre-trained on imagenet
and then we also quite importantly um
used a vocal loss as the
criteria to optimize um
this is because it's probably
quite clear in the data there's a huge
amount of imbalance
so in terms of pixels within the image
uh
you know a tiny tiny fraction are
actually albatrosses it's mostly
background
and so to overcome that we use the focal
less criterion
which places more uh weight on the
sparse and sort of rare examples
and less on easy to classify background
and so um in terms of the dataset as
well we
divided into patches because the total
satellite image is
very large it's about 30 30 000 pixels
square
um for most of the images and so we
divided them into sort of smaller
400 square patches just to put through
the network
um if that's a q and a
how do you differentiate ways from our
dresses they look like white and huge
oh yeah so the uh sorry i should have
said so that
when we're looking at the albatrosses
we're trying to count the
nesting albatrosses so um even though
there might be arbitrages over the water
um we're sort of ignoring that and
focusing on the land
and where they're nesting
so thanks for the question
and so yes so that's um
what we did for the network then
once we trained the network at end to
end it was time to look at
some results um
which is
so yeah we we sort of looked through
the put you that is
and then by thresholding at different
probabilities we calculated
our recall precision curve for the
entire
uh data set um which looked like this
on the data set that we started with so
um as we can see it's
um sort of for initial run we thought it
was quite successful it gets
maybe at best around uh 80 recall
and 80 precision on on the albatrosses
um
so we thought it was quite encouraging
but obviously there was some room for
improvement
um so we were getting about 20 error by
the way
um so when we saw these results we had a
look through and
the um the sort of rogues gallery and
tried to see if we could see any
patterns on
what the network was missing or what it
was maybe accidentally
highlighting which didn't look like an
albatross and we quickly
realized from scanning through the data
set that actually identifying whether it
was actually a true positive or a false
positive
negative was almost impossible because
they all looked
very much like albatrosses um and
this brought us back to really
realizing that we needed to properly
look at the observer confidence
so we were using one person set of
labels but actually another person
might have annotated them differently
and so
that um was something that
i realized after reading the literature
is something that comes up
really quite frequently um this
uncertainty in your ground truth
and i think one of the earliest examples
i found was of this paper by
smith in 95 which was annotating
um pictures of volcanoes on venus um
and that presents a method for sort of
uh combining observer uncertainty and
subjective labeling
and then another topic where it comes up
very frequently is in medical image
analysis
so whether doctors would maybe classify
something as a
mild moderate severe it's it's not
exactly gold standard defined
um absolute truth it's very subjective
and so we needed to factor in this
subjective interpretation
um into our own data set and so to do
this we just
um conducted some experiments where we
asked some very willing volunteers to
click on lots of white dots which was
very nice and
um and yes we set up an experimental
um room as well at uea and so they all
they did it under the same conditions
they were given the same information
prior
and just wanted to see how much they
agreed
and so that's what the experimental
protocol looked like in
arcmap um some of the key questions we
wanted to
determine were whether people
agreed um whether there was a more
agreement
for some images than other so from the
four
four pictures that we had i think you
can see in these examples
um sometimes the albatrosses are much
better contrasting to their background
like in apotras island and the
background's
quite green and so they stand out quite
clearly whereas in others where the
habitat's a bit
yellower and they're a bit harder to
distinguish and so we expected that
probably
there'd be more uncertainty for some
images than others
and then we wanted to go back and look
at a network
and given our um
new understanding of how well humans
perform on the data set
we can more accurately or assess the
results of the network within the
context of
human accuracy rather than expecting it
to achieve 100
and then we also want to consider a bit
about now that we've got a lot of
different labels
um which which one should we really use
or how can we combine these different
labels
in them in the best way and
[Music]
and so looking at the
results from the inter-observer
experiment we did find that
um there was quite a lot more agreement
for some islands than others so
approaches ireland we found that the
overall counts were
fairly consistent whereas for some uh in
bird island for example we had
a range of 600 to nearly a thousand so
there was really
quite a lot of difference and obviously
total counts don't show the whole
picture because that's just
the total number it doesn't look at
whether um
you know they could have labeled 100
completely separate points
so then this histogram shows uh the
amount of overlap or agreement between
those points so
the fraction of annotations that were
labeled by at least one person so which
is every 100
and then at least two at least three at
least four and this showed us that uh
again
as you can see uh the apotres island
had much higher agreement even at uh
all six annotations agreed
on uh you know roughly
70 of the data whereas
for bird island um or particularly the
most extreme was apotres where
around 50 they were only labeled by one
or two people so
there was a lot of uncertainty over a
large proportion of our ground truth
uh so then we also wanted to look at um
a bit more uh specifically how much
agreement there was between
individual analysts rather than sort of
averaging it out
and so to do this we sort of imagined
that
our reference observer for example
had given an absolute brown truth um
and then we could look at how well each
of the other observers
match that imagined boundary in terms of
recall and precision
so imagining that this
observer one was trying to predict the
labels that reference observer had given
and so that let us look at sort of the
accuracy between observers um
which we used as the f1 score and if we
took the average over all of those
results this gave us a mean average for
the entire
image um so for bird island it was 0.74
and so we just did that for each of the
other islands as well
and again we found that apotris had much
much higher agreement around
90 and when averaged over all of the
observers
and using this data we kind of then
went back and looked at the results from
the network to place them a bit more in
context
and so these graphs i think
maybe i just wanted to explain a bit
what they were
so from those tables we just um sort of
went back a step and rather than
plotting
f1 we plotted it as a recall precision
points in
the recall precision uh graph so this
just shows us
um the spread of observer agreement
uh obviously the the colors do kind of
correspond to each observer's ground
truth but it's
not so important it's more just showing
um the ballpark area we should be aiming
for with
uh the network performance and so for
all four of the islands those results
look like this
so you can see apaches is really tightly
clustered
towards the 90 agreement mark so that
would be where we already need to get
with the network
and so we then um
slightly retrain the network in a
cross-validation way so
we uh trained on three islands and just
tested on the remaining
unseen island to give us uh you know
remove bias in the data set um
and the results from from that network
look like this
using uh the reference observers so our
original observer
from the antarctic surveys labels as our
ground truth
and we can see um here that the bird
island results even though they were
only in the 80
mark actually due fall within the range
of human accuracy
um which was encouraging so for some of
the islands though we didn't get
um such high
[Music]
that's so close to the observers so
an ink or slightly missed the mark um
apaches as well
so this sort of gave us somewhere as a
starting point really um to look at
how well the network was achieving um
but
it's also not the full picture because
um now we have
not just one person's labels but um five
additional people's labels
and since we're training using
supervised methods we can obviously
use those labels both at the training
and also at the assessment stage
and that's going to have an impact on on
the performance of the network as well
and so then just initially we wanted to
look at
um leaving the network exactly the same
as it is
and trained on the reference and service
labels
how much would our assessment of the
performance
differ if we just chose any of the other
ground truths as our sort of gold
standard ground truth
so here we've used the reference of
service labels um
and this shows the results when we use
any of the different people's labels
and so the same exactly the same network
um trained on the reference servers
labels
would give us quite quite different
results and
yes tomorrow's facebook
i don't know how to do that sorry
i'm sorry what are you trying to do i
didn't catch it
oh sorry i just saw someone raise their
hand but i wasn't sure
it's quite unusual
sorry um attendees unfortunately cannot
use
audio so if you have a question you need
to type them in the chat
or into the q a window
so feel free to feel free to ask there
okay looks it was a mistake so we can
be on um
yes so the um
oh yeah so this is just um
we could see that there was quite a lot
of variation
um purely depending on the the ground
truth we use to assess the network
performance
um and so for example for this
uh image in the bottom left what if we
were using the
reference observers ground tree we would
have um
not scored as well as the
the observer agreement if we just chose
someone else's grand truth to assess the
results it would have fallen within the
range
um so
and then we had a little bit of a look
about and
how we could combine the labels from the
different
servers rather than just using
individuals so um
ways of doing that was a few different
ways we looked at using the intersection
so
only accepting points which are labeled
by all six observers
and we could use a majority kind of vote
um so it was labeled by
uh three or more for example or we could
look at the
union and just take any point which is
labeled by any observer
and so there's a lot of uh different
examples that we could look at for
combining uh the ground truth labels
from
from different annotators um
and that's one of the future questions
that we were going to look at as well is
um that was sort of analyzing it in
terms of the
assessment stage but we'd be quite
interested to look at how it affects the
network at the training stage as well
um so whether it's best to use an
expert's ground truth labels the
intersection majority of the union and
we could obviously also make a
probabilistic ground truth
um so assign a probability rather than a
binary
you know 100 this is an albatross point
um
and that would be something
interesting to look at and i'll sorry
there is a q a here
thank you so i don't know whether to
answer the questions now or carry on
um um i think maybe
but it's it's up to you i would say if
you think now it's a good
point to answer the question feel free
to do it or just wait
until you're done it's up to you okay
um i'll answer now then so will it be
possible to get more subjective
free ground truth on the outdoors for
instance
of course information from this website
with train footage
um
is it possible that the practice has a
better quality
yes um so i think the
in the questions one of the things i
forgot to mention was that
some of the images um
the image quality does vary a little bit
um
i'm sorry i'm so so not used to the same
thing
i think i might finish the talk and then
do the questions at the end
sure that's no problem um so
i think i've only got a couple of slides
left anyway oh yeah so then um quick
additions
that we were looking at to try and prove
um
the results to push it towards the
um human performance was one of the
images
i think this might have been one of the
questions as well um
some of the image quality does vary a
bit so for example the portrait's image
has
um some cloud cover in it and while
there's cloud cover it's still possible
to just about see albatrosses underneath
uh
so that meant that the observers
annotated it but when the network saw
the examples it generally failed at
picking up under the cloud
and because there wasn't really any
examples of that
in the training data
so one way we could potentially overcome
that is try use some augmentation
at the training phase um so some people
have used
this thing called perlin noise to sort
of generate pretend cloud
over training patches which might help
us deal with the cloud cover problem
in some of the images and then another
thing we wanted to look at was
um trying to build in some sort of
ecological factors
into the training so you
for example um prior knowledge to
exclude
areas which are unlikely to have
albatrosses which would
remove some of these false positives we
we got in this image which had a lot of
rocks which look again a lot like
albatrosses um
but which are on too steep a slope to
actually have any nesting there
um so we could potentially look at
building in elevation models or
habitat models to try and reduce the
search area
and then uh finally just wanted to
mention some
um i think quite quite exciting
developments in in these kind of
projects
uh more recently is they're being sort
of slightly scaled up
um through crowdsourcing which i think
is is quite interesting
so there's been a really uh big project
looking at
seals over the entire antarctic
coastline
um and quite a well-known one called
penguin watch which is run out of
um university of oxford and
one thing that is really useful about
these kind of um
crowdsourcing platforms uh is that you
can
just upload the image or macs are in
fact have one called geohive
who so they can upload the satellite
image directly to this interface so
there's no need for the sort of
researcher to download huge amounts of
imagery
which is also a limiting factor and you
can also
raise public awareness for the
conservation
efforts by encouraging uh crowds and
schools
and um to generate quite a lot of public
engagement by running these activities
um and again it feeds into the sort of
crowdsourcing observer uncertainty stuff
um so i think that's that's a really
exciting thing to look out for because
it allows you to process a lot more
imagery and also obviously have a
benefit um
for conservation as well and i think
that it's been
all i've got i've got thanks very much
thank you for that um wonderful talk
um so i think we have a couple of
minutes
for um questions and
you know just uh as a reminder you can
post questions in the
q a box and um ellie can
answer them um as we go along there
might be too too many to to answer
um if that's the case um
it's also possible to give a offline
answer
typed during the the next talk but we'll
see how far we get
oh yeah so um one of the questions uh
i don't know if you can see them as well
about the
um asking the reference observer to
reanalyze the data
at a later date that's um something that
was done in the original study and there
is
this aspect of i think it's rather
into observation observing so it's
true that the same person analyzes it
twice they do
produce different counts as well so
there's a there's another source of
uncertainty
there um
you know how they took changes over time
yeah and that's another thing that would
be interesting to look at how the data
changes over time so
at the moment we're a bit limited with
the number of images we have
um but gradually hopefully you'll build
up uh repeat images of the same
area so that could help us look at
what's static in the landscape like the
rocks
and what appears at different times of
the season
which would be the albatrosses um
and then it also allows you to look at
quite a lot of different stuff
in terms of the ecology as well so
rather than just doing the surveys and
getting account you can maybe look at um
you know the phonology of when certain
birds are appearing and when they're
disappearing within the season which
apparently something ecologists are
interested in as well
um
and yeah in terms of i think it's the
last one i have time for probably um
so linking it to drone footage and um
sort of ground counts uh
one of the um in the original study and
when you're um when it's possible
we sort of use the
field survey results from a well-studied
colony so in this dataset bird island is
actually
there's a permanent research station
there so they constantly
monitor the nest there on the ground and
so that information is used to validate
the methods
initially so in some well monitored
colonies we can sort of
say okay we can link this gps data
and we know that it's rapidly within the
ballpark
and that gives us some more confidence
that we can apply it to different
islands which aren't possible to access
by humans or trains
great thank you very much um if there
are any
follow up questions feel free to to post
them
and um ellie if if you are around for
the next
talk and you have the bandwidth to
answer them
um we can make that work cross this off
as done
um and then with that it's time for
next speaker so thank you very much ali
once again
um so our next speaker is um la is
carvajal
um who's going to talk to us about
moving from jupiter notebooks to
production codes
kendra akedro introduction
and lions is a developer advocate for
quantum black
and uh an i.t student with a background
in um civil and environmental
engineering
and also a co-organizer of um euro
python
2020 and the the python
by data dublin conference
so someone who is also no stranger to
the pi data universe
so with that lies if you could
share your screen absolutely
well uh good evening everyone thank you
very much for inviting me
uh thank you ellie for your talk really
really cool
i did not know that you could do that
with deep learning so interesting thank
you so much
and yes with no further ado
let me just um do this
here and
cool so can you see my sharing screen
yes wonderful cool
so let's start then so good evening
everyone hello hello hello
i'm not keeping track of the chat or the
questions
so i will just save everything for for
later on
uh if that's okay for everyone of course
and
cool so let me just position you here
wonderful so let's start
uh perfect so i will be talking tonight
to you uh
about jupiter moving from jupiter
notebooks into production code
a cadre introduction so with no further
ado let's start this
um perfect so first of all who am i
and why am i here talking to you my name
is carvalho
um as we was said already
i'm a developer advocate for quantum
black in london
uh i mean right now i'm working from
home
but the company is in london still i'm
streaming from dublin
so i'm doing my final year on i.t
and as an undergrad then my background
is a civil environmental engineering and
i have some experience with customer
service as well
uh i joined quantum black in june so
i've been found edition for
not that long and um i'm responsible for
hosting
the pi data doubling season like the
summer season
the last one of online meetups then
uh i'm a board member of python island
and i'm also a member of
a the euro python society i've been
elected like
two weeks ago so yeah it's fresh news
uh then my contact is over there as well
if you fancy get in contact with me
after um
oh um cool so what are we planning for
today
so first of all i'm gonna tell you a
little bit about quantum black and what
we do
then i will talk you i will walk you
through some um
the some of the problems uh
that are around today on data science on
the data science field um
then i will show you a solution for them
at least i'm going to try
and show you a solution for them and
then i'm going to give you
a demo that is basically going to be a
simple conversion for japan from your
peer
category project and then we're gonna
have time to do some q a
as well uh cool
so let me tell you about qb
then so we are a advanced analytics
company born out of formula one
but what does that actually mean and so
what it means is that our co-founders
used to do high performance race car
analytics and then one day they decided
to
apply those principles and to businesses
uh and that's how qb was born uh we've
been
acquired by mckenzie something around
four years ago
uh and so yeah we're in mckinsey unit
um i'm part of the quantum black labs
that is basically the product
engineering part of qb
and that's the home for casual that's
where casual came from
and i'll be talking a little bit more
about cater to you in just a moment
cool so then uh let's go then
the problem let me tell you this story
so
elsa and anna are just data scientists
that are working on the same team
and they're involved in this new project
analyzing whether a weather station in
singapore
uh elsa wrote all her coded notebook
initial standard stuff using her laptop
um and data storage
remotely but like simply remotely
let's say dropbox um everything works
great awesome so then she sends on her
notebook and a link for the data by
email
uh anna then tried to
he tries to pick up the project a little
bit earlier in the week but she can't so
she ends up
only having a look at everything on
friday at 5 00 pm
uh she managed to actually access the
notebook but she runs into an issue
loading the data she tries then to
contact elsa
just to find out that else is now on
holidays until tuesday
and while they can communicate the
project
is on hold well by the end of the day
everything is fine and they managed to
get in contact and um
everything works but collaboration is a
little bit time consuming
and it needs to be done in real time so
it's kind of hard and then it's two
years later now
and the team has grown there are now six
people
but the problems that they're having
they're facing before seems to continue
so despite the larger team
the projects are still not being
completed on time
and well now they have this thing that
the project folder is actually quite
messy with the volume of scripts that
they had
that the entire team kind of shares um
so any complex project now becomes this
very very long
notebook with hard-coded files and it's
simply a nightmare um
well because of this very long notebook
uh only one person can work on a project
at the time
and there is absolutely zero consistency
on how to develop their actual
framework uh how to actually get
everyone working together with the same
standards
uh additionally it's very hard to
find the code to reuse it and it
requires
it requires everyone that is working on
the project to keep a mental overview of
their pro
of of what's going on at all times
um so it that kind of makes everything a
little bit more
a little bit challenging and frustrating
to work
um and then they just got some
great news their boss just came over
and said um i'm gonna need this project
being deployed
into a production environment
dun dun so now we have several different
folders
everyone has their own scripts and their
own way of working
and well you can imagine how messy this
can get
now they are going to try to deploy this
to production
so the problem then becomes uh migrating
from experimentation phase to deployment
means another huge project and loads of
codes to be rewritten
um increasing the risk of actually
breaking things
and spending even more time on debugging
and refactoring
and well this also brings the whole fact
of um
you start experimenting and then you go
into deployment phase and then you
analyze what was deployed
and then maybe it wasn't necessary that
there was
that was supposed to be done then you go
back to experimentation and then do the
deployment again
and this whole this transition if this
each one of these transitions takes
weeks
uh there is a high chance that this
project is never going to be finished
and well today if a business cannot
finish project
quickly enough and it's not
really going to survive in a fast-moving
competition
instead of that cyclical graph
you would be looking then for something
ideally that would be done like this
a linear workflow instead where the goal
would
would be to build an effective system
that goes from
data consumption so ingestion of data on
the left-hand side
to module evaluation uh
and that's where all the attention is
spent
on the model so in practical terms
writing good code from the start to make
sure that all that
code there is a mess now um scales
easily
and it's easy to be put into production
it needs minimal modifications from
research and develop
in development uh the famous ind phase
into production and well less time we
spend on modifying the code to fit into
production environment
it's more time that can be invested into
model optimization
uh and code optimization to build
constraints and
etc uh cool
so then here i have a real-world
explanation on how to write good code so
we start the project and then there is
always that question do we do things
faster do we do things right
well if you're the scientist you're
probably going to choose to do things
fast that's how
most of you work um if you do things
fast well you're going to keep doing
things fast
until they work and they're kind of like
almost going to work but it's going to
be a mess of files and folders
and it's probably going to generate some
spaghetti code then if you go to the
other side
uh well you can do things right and you
can
do everything well you can do write your
code well um
there is no guarantee that your
requirements won't change
i cannot guarantee that but well if that
happens
instead of training it all out and
starting all over again you can reuse
your code
and that would help you to get into good
code
finally um which is the goal
after all cool so
then that's the end of the story so just
to summarize the problems that we faced
on that story there so we had
team collaboration is very it's
challenging uh
when everything is on one long jupiter
notebook uh
code written in notebooks are very hard
to scale
you cannot deploy a notebook into
production
it's uh rewriting that code is required
uh once you start rewriting that code
things can break
on top of that outputs on are
very less reproducible when you're
running the same code on different
machines if you're using notebooks
so the whole concept of reproducibility
since it does not exist
um it's that idea of how do i make sure
that the code that i'm seeing right here
on my local machine right now
is gonna run on my friends or my
co-workers or my friend's notebook
on on his own computer
uh and then i just want to clarify that
when i'm talking production ready code
i'm not only talking about the code
i'm talking about the other facets to it
as well like testing logging
uh continuous integration considers
deployment continuous training
documentation etc etc
uh cool so what is the solution
uh this solution then is schedule
but what is schedule so cadre is this
open source python framework
the help seems data pipelines they're
robust
consistent scalable deployable and
reproducible um
well basically that means that we use
software engineering principles
to structure your data science and
machine learning project
um we believe that if everyone has a
standard way of working together
the team can quickly come up get up to
speed on what is actually necessary for
the project
instead of spending time dwelling on
what is it that needs to be done
between us uh and well kedra allows you
to
to allows your team and your project to
grow
um enabling scalability from a single
user
to that so desired
production environment um
so the way kit is structured is
basically
here here i struggle a little bit i
never i never know to say if it's four
or five parts but you can decide so we
have a project template that is based on
cookie cutter data science
um we based our project in inspirations
from projects then with more than 80
different kokicaro data sciences uh
projects
uh we have a configuration that is
basically
configuration everywhere that um allows
you to
not hard code your file paths anymore um
and make sure that everything runs not
only locally but in the cloud or in
production environment
without the major exchanges and then the
thing that allows us to do this
is the data catalog there is basically a
yaml file
that works as a data connector so you
just
put all your all your um you're just
hard coded you code your uh
file paths in that yaml file and then
every time that the cadre project is
going to run it's going to look on that
data on the catalog.yaml first
see where your data is and then run from
there
uh we also have another file to put your
credentials in that doesn't get pushed
to github so that's quite important as
well
and then uh the needs of the business
there are
notes and pipelines so nodes are
basically
by pure python functions they have an
input
and an output and then a pipeline is a
dag so it's basically a collection of
those nodes
uh with dependencies and relationships
on them
um yeah if there's any questions that
you you think that are
urgent i need to be sorted out right now
just let me know
um cool so um
one of the things that we say is we
understand it's not that
cool to just walk in and say hey listen
we do everything much better
come to our side so we try to use
empathy
to tweak your workflow to make sure that
everyone has the same standard and
working together and they're
collaborating effectively
um and that sentence is from our poor uh
software
one of the core engineers of um pedro
she's quite cool uh cool
so i prepared a demo for us today then
so here we go
that's that that's the link for the demo
there
i don't know if you're gonna have time
enough to grab crevice but i'm going to
change the screen
right now
so uh
cool so i don't know is
everyone is still able to see me
everything okay uh yes
i can see the screen cool cool cool
perfect so uh i've prepared this quick
demo for us
then so basically this is we're gonna
start i
just typed schedule new on the terminal
um
conda environment then we installed
kedro there
uh basically we're gonna we're gonna be
facing this as soon as we open this
notebook
sorry as soon as we um type the new the
schedule new we open the new project
uh and here we have our configuration
folder where we have our base with the
catalog the data catalog i was talking
about
um over here and then the conditions one
that i was talking about as well
that holds all your access keys and
ids and everything for your data that is
not
hosted locally and then we have some
logins and then all our parameters as
well
are inside of a yaml file then
the local is the one that does not get
pushed to github so usually we just put
all the credentials inside of local
this is one of the things that we just
do it as soon as we open the boilerplate
and then here we have all the data for
the project
these layers uh here are better
explained
in our data engineering convention if
you'd like to know a little bit more
about
their engineering convention just have a
look at our documentation
uh everything is there then we have docs
a doc
docs folder uh we use sphinx for docs so
basically the only thing as soon as you
build your docs the only thing you have
to do is schedule build docs
and your dogs are gonna be there ready
for you
um then logs folder
then notebooks so here
i prepared this start notebook for us
this is gonna be super quick
um i'll open that now and then this is
the niche of our project here so the
source folder
uh this is where our nodes and pipelines
go
and this is where our pipelines are
actually there
and this is the file that runs our
schedule run
um then there's a few other stuffs over
there a few other things over there like
tests uh we use pi
tests um but yeah so let's have a look
at this jupiter notebook
so keto jupiter notebook
is gonna open that for us
here we go and then here
notebooks
perfect so um
i will use this snippet here just to
suppress those errors then we are
using python the python library requests
uh then we're requesting all the data
for this is coming from
http request there is for ace if you
heard my story
you know there is a elsa is working in a
singapore weather station
this is elsa's notebook um
so she wants to know all the data of the
the time series for this specific data
here
so we request this data
then assign it to a variable then
print the json file this is going to
take a little bit of time because it's
quite a long
file um but then
you can see it's gonna come back in a
second so then you can see
we do a little i love when this happens
it's just so good and it works
um then we have a little bit of bitter
cleaning process
um where so we have a look at the json
file you see there is a little
metadata there are stations here with
unique
ids for each one of them that they have
names and locations with latitude and
longitude
and then down here you can see there are
timestamps
and readings for each one of those
stations with the station id
and the temperature for that day uh what
elsa really
wants is um
the data for that specific for this
specific station
uh with those timestamps so temperatures
and timestamps simple easy
so let's oh what happened here oh i know
what happened here
uh cool so we're referring here to cell
number
six um cool
so here for those of you who don't know
this here allows you to just grab the
data that has been
exposed in another cell of the notebook
and just
use it over um that's the reason why
it's so
much faster cool so then here we have
our series our time series
and then well what better thing to do
than to do
a plot with this station data so we use
pandas and we generate why are you
doing this to me
um oh i don't have pandas
i wonder if i have to put this in
another in another
cell no i don't wonderful so here we go
our graph uh but
simple stuff and then uh let's go to the
meat of the business so how do we
convert this into
yeah i'm running out of time so let me
let me go faster so how do we convert
this into
a schedule project so first of all we
need to make sure that these are
functions
so casual works with pure python
functions uh
the way i did it was basically i just
copied everything if you look over here
i just copied the same the same things
that are here
and these three cells and wrapped into a
function
here we go that's it and then i did the
same thing for the other one for the
choosing state
i could call the choose station function
um
it's all over here i made a variable for
the
notebook cell number and i thought it
was a little bit better practice
um and wrapped everything around that
function
so to convert this we basically go um
view so view cell toolbar and tags
then here make sure you baptize this as
a node so here we go if you do
node it becomes a node and then a node
here
as well uh so we close this
then we go back into our pycharm
let me
uh where is pycharm this time
cool we go back into pycharm and
um you're
messing up with my
sorry a quick confusion with
uh virtual environments
who so if you do pedro jupiter
no quedro jupiter
converge oh
um and if it works it's gonna
wonderful so it's asking me here so it's
grabbing
the jupiter notebook it's searching the
entire
project directory looking for the
jupyter notebook and then it's telling
me that it's gonna
it's gonna output on this file but
keep in mind that i already have this
file over here because i did this before
this file over here that has the same
name of the notebook with all my
functions inside so it's asking me if i
want to override it or not
i'm going to say no because i'm running
out of time
but you can see how it's done right if
you have any questions
just hit me up after this so basically
we have
this here that you can see it's exact
the same as
our functions over here it's basically
just a
easy way of converting it then how to
make this into a character project
so you need to make sure that you go
into hooks um
that you import your functions here
um and then attribute your nodes
so i wrote this code already because i
knew i was going to be running out of
time
but i walk you through it quite quickly
so
here we have node 1 where
we get this node getting data
where the import is none and the output
is
raw temperatures then we have this other
node
where i choose the station it's the
outer function
that takes as inputs the rod temperature
there is output from here
and the station id that is the actual
name of that station and outputs the
temperature
and then to output that plot i would
need a third
node that doesn't necessarily have a
function um
so i just use aluminum function here and
tell to plot to use much profit to plot
this
as the temperature blush then the way
the
schedule knows where all this is is you
go into the catalog
sorry you go into the catalog and then
here you have raw temperature
there is a json data search that is
coming from the requests
uh this is the data in the file path and
the temporary path
that is a much broad lab type and this
is the file path
so if i go here then and do a catro
run
[Music]
so it's showing me that it's running the
first node
yeah temporary data
usually when i do this using zoom
everything crashes
so
go everything run wonderful so
here we have 10 so there's all the steps
so one note out of three
then three notes on a three and then
sorry two nodes out of three and then
three nodes are retrieved
uh it's ran so if you wanna see the same
graph
uh since i said here eight report temp
we go back here into
data and then reporting and then here's
our graph
see it looks like a little bit of
overwork for this
but imagine if you have all your data
cleaning functions there
and you need to make sure that they're
all in pipelines
um also i'm just i'm just illustrating
and then i have something cool to show
you as well
now that is our visualization tool
uh so if you look here you can see that
we have other functions there so we have
our
get temporary data function and that is
outputted into
raw temp um then for the choose station
function
we have an input as inputs raw temp and
station id um that go
inside here and then they output the
temperature and then
the temperature is inputted into our
laminar function
and outputs the temporary flush if you
like for example to see
if where the raw temp for example works
you could just select that node and you
can see that the parameter station
wait the param station here doesn't
it it's off which means this rod
temperature node does not
influence into the parameter station id
this doesn't actually make that much
difference when you look into a deck
that is this small
but if you look into a much bigger tag
um it's
easy to see uh cool
so now how long do i still have let me
see
two minutes so real quick
let me go back here um
and show you then so we have a few
plugins out of the box for support we
have kedrovis
that i just showed you um you this is
the official link for a much bigger
visualization that you can just play
with it it's quite a cool bag
you can use docker to just ship your
your projects and you can also um
hook your credit project to airflow um
then uh well so we are open source but
we are enterprise open source so we are
actively maintained by
quantum black and there is a team of
schedule core developers behind this
all this amazingness um we are
on stackoverflow we are on github we
love pull requests
uh our documentation is also we try our
best with our documentation
please give us some feedback if you try
there's something you can understand
just make a pull request and send us a
question um
then i want to just give you a quick uh
show on the ketter community so we have
a few
very very very active contributors like
dpiment that
huge um a plugin for us and there's also
mr dairy engineer one there's tam
and has a youtube channel on kedro uh
doing some
quirky stuff uh
then we have uh waylon walker there is
one of our oldest
users that also been writing some cool
stuff
and yusuki minami is a data scientist in
singapore
and he's also a kaggle master
and he built pipeline x that is
supported that is supported by pedro i
mean
um it's compatible with casual and he
also built castro lyft
if you're looking for something to do
like the heavy lifting of your data
pipelines
uh and one of the coolest things that he
built for us
is like this comparison graph with all
these different um
data pipelines um tools it's quite
interesting you can have a look at that
on his github profile
and then there is a new casual community
channel
that come out this came out this week
we're super super super happy about it
uh it's a channel that you can just go
there and ask questions publish your use
case
share your data pipeline worries brag
about the projects you did anything you
want to do
we're more than happy to have you there
just hop in
and then there are mentored sprints as
well coming
we have uh one next week on pycon india
then there's jupiter khan and then we're
also on pi data global sprints
and we also have a super cool
spotif spotify playlist uh cadre lounge
please hop in as well that's the link
over there
and we in qb are
hiring so if you're interested on
working for the super cool company
you could be producing your next open
source too just
give me a shout after this and yes
that's all i'm done now i'm stop sharing
thank you very very much liz for the
engaging talk
um i think the problems that you
highlighted early on
very cute and very painful for a lot of
us
um with that so we have um
a question that's posted
and we probably have a couple of minutes
for for questions
so feel free to to ask and i'll let you
take it away
with the questions
we have lost our speaker
i have i have one question maybe that
gives the audience time to think of more
so thanks for the talk i'm i'm curious
at my workplace we have
constantly discussions about whether we
should
open source this software and that
software right i mean it's
it's a lot of work for for the developer
set quantum black you need to write
a lot more documentation you need to
give support to your open source users
you need to respond to issues on github
it's it's a it's a huge investment right
so what do you know what was the reason
for for quantum black or mckinsey to go
open source with cadre
what are you hoping for absolutely uh so
uh the reason why we open source
schedule that's a great question by the
way
um so yeah the reason why we opened star
schedule initially was because
we were using dash we're using the
schedule
for our data analytics project on in
consultancy
and then we were leaving the companies
and um
our customers are like oh but wait um
you're leaving already like what about
now what do we do
um we need we need support and we're
like well we can't really
give you supports just for this specific
tool
what we can do is open sources so we
decided then to open source that for the
benefits of our stakeholders
it was a lot of work i wasn't in the
company at the time but i've heard
there was a lot of work um
and it's still a lot of work especially
trying to build a community around it
um there is a lot of work to be done
absolutely but
um well i personally i believe that the
future of software is
open source that that's how we're going
to actually get to make a difference
and engage with people and build not
like not only share
features but actually to share knowledge
um
software needs to be open source
okay makes sense thank you very much
you're very welcome
and this is one more question
in the chat so uh there's a question
would the schedule tutorial work with
google collab
as well uh
google collab what is google collab i'm
not i'm not
i'm sorry but i'm not familiar with it
um it's google's way of
running machine learning notebooks in
the cloud with
google magic behind it uh
i actually wasn't i actually wasn't um
aware of that
well so schedule to use casual you need
to install it
locally what we do um
what we do allow you to do
is um having your i mean
one of the most awesome things is you
can have your data stored remotely
um but a cadre needs to be installed
locally
unless i guess you're having like if you
have a server hosted somewhere and you
want to
install schedule on that server but i'm
not really sure
how that would work so i hope that
answers your questions room
i think this sounds like a exciting new
plugin waiting to be
developed it could be it could be
so then i have another question here and
kqjn and so how does schedule
handle classes so uh cadre is built on
pure python functions
um so basically the same way that you
write your scripts with classes is
how classes should be written with
schedule how it works
under the hood um i would love to sit
down and show you some uml graphs
and we could talk about a little bit of
under the hood stuff
um but i yeah i don't i wouldn't be
comfortable
like just telling you right now what is
it this specific the specific
steps of how schedule operates
um basically what i can tell you in a
nutshell
is um you go catro run cadre run goes
into run.pi
and run.fi does a few checks like the
com folder
for the comforter for your configuration
so base local
um then it runs to find
it runs into hook stop by to find how
your pipelines are structure
and what are the functions in your
pipeline and then goes into your node
folder looking for the actual functions
to run your nodes
um and that's kind of how schedule phase
also
works but yeah for now that's it uh does
that answer your question do you
want me to go into more detail maybe
i i have maybe a quick technical
question um
so you on the last slide in the plugins
you showed this
kidro airflow plug-in um
but if you don't install that to do
what's
what is used under the hood to to run
the pipeline
can can you talk about that uh cool yeah
so to run the actual pipelines
is so yeah we have the the schedule
airflow is just a plug-in that you can
plug it in if you like to see if you use
um
airflow to show your dags for example
and you're like
not really in the mood to use schedule
vis uh
so you can use that and you can also use
for deployment so like you can
push your ci cd with using airflow a
little bit better you can use containers
with airflow as well uh so but the way
that casual runs
under the hood uh yeah so basically i
have this
cool uml graph here uh let me see if i
can find it for you
so basically uh you go catch your
casual run is that the trigger so you
basically go catch your run
then when you go catch or run um we have
this
run.pi file and then that run.pi
file is the one that that has all the
runners so if you think about casual
as a um train
then the ren.5 would be the actual
engine that would make the entire thing
run so let me just get my phone to get
this authorization thing going on this
push here so i can show you that
uml graph um
yes so then after that so then inside of
k it's inside of 1.5
he runs um so he goes into
the conf folder so it goes into base for
the um
sorry uh comforter so local and base
um looking for specifics inside of those
so looking for your data catalog there's
the first thing you're gonna need to
have
um there so your data entries so the
range is for your code and um
it does as well so and then it goes
into goes into your pipelines folder
to see how the pipelines are structured
so what is the order and what are the
dependencies
and then after it kind of grasps that it
goes into each one of the nodes
uh the nodes folder the nodes.pi files
and look for those functions and see
what exactly is the transformation that
the data has to do
um i am not as
technical as i wish i was and to answer
you that question the way that i think
you deserve
but if you can can you see can you see
my screen oops
cool so here if i can
give a little bit more um
no don't know how this works
maybe if i open this like this let me
see
sorry about that
sorry i i wouldn't worry too much about
it i put you on the spot
by asking you to lift up the lid i'm
more than happy to
dive into the excellent documentation
that you have
the documentary we're proud of our
documentation to be honest with you
um our technical editor is putting a lot
of effort into that
and she's quite cool as well so yeah
here it is if you if you're still
interested
so there it is so first it goes into the
execution
so you execute it's basically the casual
run it goes into run it looks for the
data catalog in the actual pipeline
and then inside of the data catalog
you're going to have your data sets
there are your dictionaries and then
you're going to have a load and save
and then um yeah so loads from and saves
to the data such
and then up here you actually have your
carriages of the
your train so how it
runs from one side to another um
yeah any other questions
i don't see any more questions
i think that means that we're officially
at the end
of our meet up cool please thank you
again
and also thank you to ellie our previous
speaker so
both very interesting talks um to
everybody
thank you for attending uh both the
slides from
the meetup and the recording will be
made available later on
and in the meantime please give our
speakers
a virtual thumbs up leave a nice comment
follow them on twitter
check out our work on github and yeah
basically
stay in touch thank you very much
everybody
thank you thank you for hosting thank
you for the great reception
and thank you bruce as well for saying
he's gonna
he's gonna try catherine his next
project i love it thank you
and i hope you had as much fun as i did
thank you very much
thank you thank you very much